Speaker 1: Let's go next to um. Oh, where
are we going? There's so many interesting
callers. Let's go to Louie from New
Brunswick. Louie, you're on the air.
Speaker 3: Hey, good afternoon, David.
Speaker 1: Can you hear me? I can hear you. Fine.
Speaker 3: So really, enjoy your show for some
caller, longtime listener. My wife and I find
ourselves in a strange situation, OK? We were
part of a church that's very, very right leaning,
but politically we're the opposite, except for
some key issues. We feel like we have to almost
keep it under wraps. Our political bent.
But we really have a hard time discussing
just just as common issues with our with our
brothers and sisters. Have you have you ever
encountered anything like this before and will do?
Speaker 1: Yeah, I mean, I guess in some sense,
I have in that. There, I mean, listen, I'm
not a religious Jew, I'm culturally Jewish,
ethnically Jewish, Colin narrowly Jewish, I'm not
religious, but there are people in my circles who
are more religiously devout Jews, and they have
much more culturally conservative views. But
it's not really become a problem. It's just
like, I know those are their views and they
know my views. Let me ask what what denomination
or what is this? Is this a Christian church?
Speaker 3: It is. It's a Christian church.
We're basically a non-denominational.
And the funny thing is that our congregation is
becoming extremely multicultural. I'll give you
a quick example. We had a Christmas. Well, it's an
advent children's concert I would like to say, and
I want to say 90 percent of the children were
nonwhite. OK? And it was agreed. Say, like,
you know, our leadership is saying things
like, Look, if our if our community is very
multicultural, then the church should represent
that. Right. So I love that. I love that. However,
I've noticed that. A lot of the the men in the
leadership, or I would say not the leadership.
A lot of the men who are very engaged are a
lot more, I would say, Caucasian and then skew
heavily towards. I hate to say this, but Trumpism?
Speaker 1: Well, I mean, let me just ask you what
what's like a big issue on which you disagree
with the general position of the church?
Speaker 3: Well, that's just it. It's not a
position of the church to follow politics,
but but but when a lot of people, you know,
we're like just spouting things that they heard
on Fox News and worse, like Newsmax. Yeah, it's
really it's really horrible. Like, for example,
we were in a prayer meeting and someone was like,
like praying against Nancy Pelosi. It was like
it was literally like a Fox News talking point.
Speaker 1: Now, in a situation, I mean, listen,
I don't know anything about churches, but in a
situation like that, couldn't you stand up and
say, Listen, guys, it's not appropriate for us to
be involving politics in this way. I'm not making
a statement for or against anyone.
I'm just saying this is a place for
faith and community, not for politics. Could could
you say that or would that not be well-received?
Speaker 3: Well, we have said that actually in our
men's meeting, we've made a point that we shall
not ever talk politics because it's so divisive,
right? And and when I've confronted people one on
one about, say, like hypocrisy of Trump or like
that he lies or he's like a, you know, he's abused
women or done horrible things. I've noticed it.
It hurts people's feelings like they they recoil
like they were, you know, personally injured. So
so my wife and I've learned just not even to bring
it up, and we just cringe and kind of like, just
hold our tongue when, when, when things come up,
Speaker 1: could you find a more liberal
church? I mean, is that an option? I mean, I
understand it's a big deal to change churches,
I'm sure. But but is it to the point where you
would say, I want to find a different church?
Speaker 3: Well, it's funny that you bring that up
because a lot of people who have spoken about this
outside the church say stuff like that, like, why
don't you leave? Do like, why are you still there?
And you know what it is is like, there's so
much love. There's so much relationships.
We've been there for over 10 years. We feel
like we feel like it would be like abandoning
it is just not an option. It's worth it,
I think, just to like, stay in the labor
of love and like to see how things turn out.
Speaker 1: Well, in that case, it sounds like
you have your answer as to what to do, right?
Speaker 3: Yeah, yeah, you're right. Yeah,
we're staying.
Speaker 1: Yeah,
yeah, yeah. He's I'm pretty, pretty
confident about that. All right. Well,
let me know how it goes. And
by the way, I mean, listen,
you're not saying that from the pulpit. They're
doing politics right because that's actually
against the church charter for nonprofits.
Speaker 3: Right, no, they're not. There's
even when even when Trump was like flying high and
things were like, you know, in their perspective,
because now it's the opposite, like, you
know, it's it's almost like a shame now,
I think for even for Trump to talk about Trump,
but or to defend him, I should say. But even when
when he was flying high, I would say, like
early in his in his administration. Yeah,
there were times where I have a feeling that
the pastor crossed a line and people had to
talk to him and say, You need to, you need
to dial that back like, Oh, you can't. Yeah.
So it's a struggle, especially with the older,
the older generation, I would say, like over 50,
over 60. Got it. Got it. All right. Well, for
Speaker 1: taking the pulpit on how it goes. Yeah,
thanks. Louie Louie from New Brunswick dealing.
That's quite a matzo ball hanging out there that
he's dealing with proverbially. Of course,
I know it's a Christian, a Christian church.